hello everyone
welcome back to our Channel
today's episode is going to be unique
because we are tackling a very
interesting topic
the power of literature with a focus on
Arabic semantics in the most General
sense literature is a discipline that
studies elegant measured and harmonious
words uttered or written in verse or
prose in a form that is congruent with
the conditions of time and usually in
compliance with the rules of the
language the Arabic word for literature
is adeb which has a wider frame of
connotation associated with good manners
gentleness elegance refinement and
Perfection it has often been interpreted
in relation to a person's lifestyle
conduct and integrity and as a means to
the flourishing of that person in
spirituality and purification of the
heart
in this sense the word adab in Arabic
which is literature falls in the domain
of books on ethics and of treatises on
Sufism and therefore it is not usually
covered with the discipline of
literature
it is possible to refer to an indirect
connection between the two
moving on from this relation I would
like to open a small window onto the
meaning of literature as I understand it
however I must first beg that my readers
and my listeners pardon my humble
statements on a subject that is in fact
beyond my ability and since I'm not
specialized in this field I'm going to
give my humble opinion and that they
judge this as a not only on how it
stands but for the good intentions with
which it was uh written or it's it's
been spoken I actually confess that just
as I and people like me with narrow
Horizons cannot judge matters even in
our own field properly so too it is very
difficult for us to express other
matters very clearly even when we may
have judged them correctly and I think
this is generally true for or
of all who tackle this topic for
instance after uh one of the scholars
had had personally corrected his book
and afterwards still others had
repeatedly corrected it he found that
certain points still bothered him so he
raised his hand and admitted that no
book can be faultless except for the uh
holy books
even if most books hold any value in
terms of being the reflection or an echo
of the Beauties the book possesses uh
most books and most works of literature
can hold absolutely no individual value
of their own because they're absolutely
only figures and interpretations of
someone else's wider scope of knowledge
nevertheless this reality should never
dishearten uh our our uh intentions or
paralyze our determination to work we
should always think speak plan and
always try to realize what we have
planned and while doing all this we
should never forget that we can
occasionally make mistakes that we often
uh can fall into error this is natural
and as soon as we recognize our errors
we will try and correct them try and
compensate for shortcomings and stick to
seeking the best possible alternative
so these humble contemplations must be
seen in the same way speech was born
with Humanity developed with humanity
and it constitutes a very significant
depth of Being Human
so speech reached its contemporary level
of maturity through history after having
been repeatedly distilled through
countless filters of thought and fashion
by masters of words and then became what
we now call it literature in this
respect it can be argued that the
present moment of literature is brighter
than its past thus it can be also be it
can also be said that so too its future
will be brighter than the present or at
least it should be so
as one one of those colors explains
human being
as one of those colors explains and says
that human beings will eventually turn
completely toward knowledge so that they
will derive their power from knowledge
as a result the ultimate say will pass
into the hands of knowledge at the stage
when knowledge shows such a level of
development the command of language and
eloquence reaching its peak will
outweigh all other values possibly in
such a period in order to make others
accept their ideas people will use
language as a weapon
they will also try to penetrate Hearts
through their facility with language and
Conquer Souls with the charm of
literature except hearts are going to
try and penetrate their minds through
the facility of this language
the reality of knowledge and speech
manifested only concisely in uh one of
the the ancient Scholars it reached its
most brilliant form with uh the final
the final stage which is today's stage
yielded its awaited fruit and became
fully realized in uh the books that we
have today now if the world is going to
last any longer in the years ahead well
knowledge reaches its speak language
dual risk to the rank of The Interpreter
of knowledge in almost all circles
accompanied by the most powerful of
orators and richest of speeches of
voicing the truth the power of
expression which is always nourished and
develops in the bosom of need and
necessity will flourish in the in this
environment for one last time
make its voice heard as powerfully as it
can will be its greatest goal if you
will you could also say that this will
be the the reliving of the age of the
Golden Ages frankly in its most mature
State an age where Love Of Truth and
Love of knowledge we're zealed to
understand and the passion to explain
where human values and their
appreciation will live alongside one
another
incidentally I would like to underline
one point
future architects of thought and masters
of language should do whatever they can
to protect it and honor the power of
expression for it has fallen into being
capable hands of people like us they
should untie its tongue so that it can
voice our own worlds of thoughts
otherwise it is obvious that we will
keep on hearing the calling and crowds
where we expect to hear the singing of
Nightingales we will not be able to be
free of the distress of thorns on the
way to roses the power of speech and
refinement of eloquence have always
developed found its proper consistency
and came to maturity in the realm of
literature and under the tutalag of
literature however it is also very
important that we understand or we are
supposed to understand when literary
thought or literature is mentioned
human beings have always expect human
beings have always expressed their
feelings thoughts and Inspirations of
their heart through cinema theater and
symbolic painting along with oral or
written literature when the subject
extends Beyond spoken or written
language naturally gesture facial
expression sounds and other means
replays words and sentences
even so they have never been able to
truly substitute for speech and writing
the most reliable way for people to
preserve their literature and make it
flourish in its own framework and
fertile ground is to put it into a
written form
this turns in turns it into a common
source to which individuals may refer to
at any time it allows it to become as
widely accessible as possible Paving the
way for it to become the national style
of an entire Society the nation's shared
property it thus becomes a field of
exposition of future Generations an
exhibition ground of verbal excellence
and a trust to the common conscious
guarded by national memory and and
perpetuating its own origin in this
respect we have always thought
literature in the magical world of
written or spoken words and always
realized our acquaintance and encounters
with it among the pages of books and
magazines whatever style is adopted in
recounting a given subject whether the
work produced is approached with an
artistic concern or expressed in a
playing style whether a small select
audience is targeted or large Crowds Are
addressed when literature is mentioned
what comes first to mind is the red word
it doesn't make any difference whether
the subject of a piece of literature is
a religion an idea of philosophy or
doctrine literature is one of the most
important ways that humans can transfer
the accumulation of knowledge they have
gained through history from one
generation to another
through literature they can sense all
the depths and richness of yesterday in
the present they see the past and
present as two dimensions of reality and
Savor the future in its relative death
furthermore most people and communities
should firstly be faithful to their
Heritage and refer to it frequently as
much as they Embrace Universal human
values which are called modern or
modernization they should emphasize the
essence of their common conscience and
take it as an essential constituent they
should use this Heritage as the canvas
for the Embroidery in which they depict
their literary feelings and
understanding of art so that they do not
destroy the spirit of their own
literature and are not constrained
solely to foreign borrowings if they use
their own sources and weave their own
cultural values on their own Loom there
does not seem to be an obstacle to their
progress
and uh they can walk to the universality
carrying the interpretations of their
own time
well it should play is the main source
of belief cultural heritage and memory
of universal values in the center of
their lives thus after having secured
themselves from deviation people should
strive to establish connections with
this outside world remaining indifferent
to others values restrict what is
normally Broad and Universal is an
obstruction to growth causing Agony for
the living and failing uh to understand
and also falling from the degree of
being an envied to a state of envying
others the condition of third world
countries today presents so many living
examples of of that
these countries always go through a
period of standstill in their literature
sometimes due to costumes sometimes
because of the influence of local
understanding which can be empathized to
a certain extent but not all of it
approaching literature liberally to a
large degree ceased due to excessive
reactions some very important sources of
inspiration were dried up and efforts to
enrich literature were perceived as
fantasy and subsequently dismissed
moreover the field of literature was
further narrowed at certain times by
favoring a region or a dialect at the
expense of other varieties of the
language the branches with potential to
develop were cut off and The Roots were
removed by prohibiting the field of
literature from being plowed
thus in such countries the development
of a language that may have been more
representative of the wider Society was
prevented and instead of dialect on the
margins had been preferred over others
and as a result their literature was
reduced to the voice of a small minority
rather than becoming a respectable
representative of literature in the
world this can also be called
surrendering the Oblivion in fact what
becomes dormant stops growing and what
is not open to developing Withers
whatever is static then topples over and
that which does not give fruit dies this
is not limited to literature it is true
for almost every subject from science to
thought from art to philosophy and so on
nevertheless literature does not simply
mean playing on Words With written or
spoken language skills and producing
phrases people will like it means making
the art of expression lovable with the
dimensions of eloquence and Clarity it
is the Water and Air of feeding adorning
and enriching Daily Language with the
cleanest purest most lovable and Lasting
material and it is a treasure which
increases with use
a writer verse or prose who pens his or
her thoughts with literary
considerations always relies upon a
purpose and overtone using a rich
vocabulary harmonious statements and a
grand style writers activate words long
and short aiming for excellence of
expression well moving towards this aim
writers place all the words or sentences
they have picked and fitted in their
places in such a way that they all sound
out like notes serving to support the
general theme of the tune they play as
these sounds and notes voice their
intended ideal they continue to play in
the background reflecting the author's
mode of thinking General Tendencies and
mood in a lyric verse produced by a
massive expression the words feel as if
they are filled with that person's
excitement the words sentences or lines
springing from a literary heart the word
sentence or lines springing from a
literary heart kindled with epic
feelings a ring in our ears like the
march of a glorious Army all the words
in a masterfully written drama resonate
in the deaths of our soul and almost
bring life to the story therein a
literary person is able to think very
differently and reach different
judgments writers always pursue quality
and strive to leave future Generations a
legacy they will gladly inherit and
respect
actually like literary language Daily
Language also has its own kind of beauty
is Allure and naturalness that entices
Pure Pleasure however literary language
is poetic Musical and constructs a
pleasing whole in harmony with the
meanings it holds
it is Superior in linguistic utilization
taste and refinement in the way that
demonstrates coherence within the text
as a whole and cohesion between words
and sentences
let alone feeling and savoring these it
is sometimes a very difficult for people
who lack the attitude to even understand
them all that notwithstanding it is not
correct to regard literary style as a
language of an upper class or an
aristocratic group on the contrary even
if they cannot penetrate as far as the
secondary meanings and connotations
suggested by the composition people of
every level should somehow be able to
understand and they should be able to
benefit from that Source even if only in
a limited way
so in time they will be elevated to a
level where they can express their
feelings and thoughts more comfortably
and gain greater language skills through
the expression of their knowledge
in the meantime they will consolidate
what they already know of language
enrich it by making suitable
contributions as far as they can and add
new depths to their Horizon of thought
no matter at what level the language
almost all of us speak today which has
quietly settled in our memories through
generations is to a great extent the
fruit of Master poets
and writers concerted efforts that have
been adopted by ourselves with the
sensitivity of a Goldsmith these masters
of expression presented us with the
beautiful jewels of expression and
necklaces of words that they prepared
thanks to their legacy we express
ourselves through this rich source to
the best of our abilities
even though not everybody understands
the Magnificent Works they produced and
the aesthetic depths in the spirit of
these works all of us have always
appreciated them and felt eager for more
for such a level of appreciation one
does not need to know the writer's
artistic anxiety power to construct
mental strain success in planning nor
his or her True Value to the extent of
skillful Goldsmith knows the precious
stones people have always held the
literary artists in high regard
certainly with exceptions they have
applauded these people's efforts
appreciated their labor and frequently
expressed this appreciation by imitating
them then what Falls to literary people
is that they put their language skills
and artistic talents at the service of
their right good and beautiful instead
of hurting The Souls of the masses who
can be regarded as their apprentices by
describing what is corrupt or
contaminating people's pure Thoughts
with dirty images and condemning them to
the slavery of materialism with
descriptions of carnal desires only
according to a scholar people of letters
need to have high morals and act within
the universal codes of conduct
prescribed in Divine scriptures he also
reminds us of the Divine Source where
the power of expression originates from
and advises us to duly respect this
capacity which is regarded as an
important death of our Humanity literary
styles of expression are different than
other styles for example in scientific
writing or speech it is essential to
have a sound pattern of reasoning a
systematic thought to well-versed
statement and no mental logical and
emotional gaps should be left unfilled
oratory style emphasizes proofs and
arguments maintaining interest and
enthusiasm making occasional repetitions
supporting the narration with
paraphrases when necessary using
colorful expression and and living the
speech by inspirational shifts without
detracting from the main axis on the
other hand literary style requires a
variety of linguistic Arts such as
vividness of expression accuracy of
language beauty of presentation richness
of imagination and utilization of
metaphors Parables idioms figures of
speech and Illusions as long as it does
not reach the point of excess because
success will spoil as in everything else
the naturalness of language and Modi the
Heavenly spring of expression people of
sound taste will mostly find it strange
as another scholar also expressed the
wording should be as ornate as the
nature of the meaning allows forms
should follow content and while it is
being crafted permission for literary
license should be requested from the
meaning in order to avoid excess the
brightness and resplendance of style
should be given proper due but the aim
and intended meaning should never be
neglected the imagination should be
given room to maneuver but not at the
cost of the truth
[Music]
thank you for listening to our podcast
if you really like this episode make
sure to go and subscribe to our Channel
and also sign up in the emails list if
you want similar stuff
that's it for today I'll see you next
time